[Música]
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
exigió garantías de seguridad inmediatas
a la otan y eeuu el mandatario sigue
reclamando que la alianza atlántica-
ponga fin a su expansión hacia el este y
rechace el ingreso de ucrania putin
aseguró que la respuesta rusa dependerá
de las garantías de occidente a sus
solicitudes
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu aprobó el uso del
mol nubira o ir contra el coi 19 se
trata del segundo tratamiento oral
autorizado desarrollado por la
farmacéutica merck está indicado para
adultos con riesgos de hospitalización
que presenten síntomas tempranos
la icónica estatua que conmemoraba la
matanza de tiananmen en 1989 conocida
como el pilar de la vergüenza fue
retirada de la universidad de hong kong
el hecho ha sido calificado como el más
reciente revés para las libertades en
ese territorio semiautónomo como un
nuevo intento del gobierno chino por
reescribir la historia
buenos días para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez iniciamos
este informativo en rusia porque el
presidente vladimir putin exigió a eeuu
y a la otan que ofrezcan garantías
inmediatas para la seguridad de rusia el
mandatario les advirtió que podría
empantanar las negociaciones previstas
para inicios de 2022 ante los temores de
una eventual invasión rusa a ucrania
país con el que putin aseguran no buscar
conflicto el líder del kremlin dijo que
las acciones de rusia dependerá de las
garantías que reciba por parte de
occidente rusia exige que la alianza
militar atlántica ponga fin a su
expansión hacia el este y rechace el
ingreso de ucrania al bloque
los registros de vigencia de nuestras
acciones dependerán no del proceso de
negociación y sino de la seguridad
incondicional de rusia tanto hoy como en
la perspectiva histórica con respecto a
esto hemos dejado claro y de manera
explícita que hubo un mayor movimiento
de la otan hacia el este es inaceptable
y que no queda claro somos nosotros los
que ponemos misiles cerca de las
fronteras estadounidenses no es estados
unidos el que ha venido con sus misiles
hasta nuestra casa están en la puerta de
nuestra casa cuando mónaco youtube
hablamos ahora de kobe 19 la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu autorizó el uso del
molino pira beer la píldora del
laboratorio merck contra el hobbit 19 el
organismo explicó que está indicada para
adultos que enfrentan un alto riesgo de
hospitalización incluidas personas
mayores o aquellas con condiciones como
obesidad o problemas cardíacos la
pastilla que es el segundo tratamiento
oral aprobado está contraindicada para
menores de 18 años y mujeres embarazadas
entretanto por segundo año consecutivo
eeuu tendrá una navidad marcada por el
coi 19 esto a medida que se registra el
incremento de casos por la variante
omicron millones de personas se preparan
para salir de vacaciones o encontrarse
con sus seres queridos pero temen
ponerlos en riesgo con este nuevo linaje
del virus andrés meza muñoz tiene los
detalles
faltan pocas horas para navidad y las
celebraciones todavía aparecen inciertas
para los estadounidenses debido a la
variante omicron que se propaga con
rapidez por todo el país lo que se
agudizaría con los viajes masivos de
diciembre
mucha gente en mi trabajo acaba de dar
positivo todavía sigo negativo así que
definitivamente los últimos días en
particular con los máximos históricos
tengo muchas dudas sobre viajar
según los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades omicron que
se cree que es más contagiosa representa
el 73 por ciento de los casos en el país
y tal como ocurrió al inicio de la
pandemia los sitios de pruebas se
encuentran abarrotados de personas que
buscan descartar un contagio antes de ir
a reunirse con sus familiares si doy
positivo simplemente me quedaré en la
ciudad no visitaría la familia así que
cruzaré los dedos para que sea una
prueba negativa el sector turístico fue
uno de los más afectados durante los
estrictos cierres del año pasado por lo
que hoy las compañías de viajes se
mantienen optimistas y esperan que
quienes recibieron la vacuna puedan
seguir adelante con sus planes sin
embargo del 72 por ciento de los
estadounidenses inoculados sólo el 61
por ciento tiene la pauta completa antes
del incremento de los casos de omicron
la asociación estadounidense del
automóvil estimaba que entre el 23 de
diciembre y el 2 de enero unos 109
millones de ciudadanos viajarían por
tierra o aire
pero ahora temen que la propagación de
la variante pueda provocar cancelaciones
masivas
y vamos a reino unido donde dos estudios
preliminares uno escocés y otro inglés
sugieren que la severidad de los
síntomas causados por la variante del
virus del coi 19 es menor al compararla
con el linaje delta lo que conllevaría a
un menor número de hospitalizaciones
esto confirma una tendencia que en
principio fue observada en sudáfrica sin
embargo los expertos alertan de la alta
transmisibilidad y piden no bajar la
guardia
y si la variante omicron es menos
peligrosa que sus predecesoras y en
particular que la delta esta es la tesis
apoyada por el prestigioso imperial
college de londres y es que a pesar del
nuevo récord de contagios en reino unido
donde el miércoles se detectaron a 106
mil casos los expertos se muestran algo
optimistas para ello compararon dos
curvas la de contagios exponencial
frente a la curva de hospitalizaciones
en muy ligero aumento sus primeras
conclusiones los pacientes con la
variante omicron tienen entre un 20 y un
25% menos de probabilidades de contraer
una forma grave de la enfermedad
respecto a los que contraen la variante
delta es como un grito ficha
lo que vemos en inglaterra es que hay
más pacientes hospitalizados en lo que
llamamos camas convencionales se les da
oxígeno y no necesitan ser entubados en
cuidados intensivos y lyon o reanimación
una tendencia que ya se observó en
sudáfrica donde detectaron un micrón por
primera vez el mes pasado a nivel local
los casos están disminuyendo
el pico de la ola no coincidió con el
aumento significativo de muertes según
otro estudio es más probable que la
nueva variante afecte a los vacunados y
a los jóvenes poblaciones de bajo riesgo
que tienen menos probabilidades de ser
hospitalizadas que los no vacunados el
brote de kobe 19 en reinounido forzó al
aplazamiento de dos partidos de la
premier league programados para este
domingo se trata de los encuentros entre
el liverpool y leeds y wolverhampton
contra watford tanto leads como watford
pidieron que se pospusiera la jornada y
la junta directiva de la premier aceptó
tras reconocer que la decisión causará
decepción entre los aficionados
en otras noticias de la noche a la
mañana en la universidad de hong kong
retiro una estatua que conmemoraba a los
manifestantes a favor de la democracia
que fueron asesinados en la plaza de
tiananmen en 1989 el pilar de la
vergüenza el nombre que dio a la obra su
creador se erigió como símbolo de
libertad de expresión ahora después de
dos décadas la estatua se ha ido
al amparo de la noche los trabajadores
retiran el pilar de la vergüenza una
escultura de unos ocho metros compuesta
por cuerpos retorcidos y 50 rostros
angustiados representa los asesinatos de
partidarios de la democracia en la plaza
tiananmen en 1989 el jueves por la
mañana a los estudiantes y espectadores
de la universidad de hong kong intentan
vislumbrar el lugar donde una vez estuvo
la estatua
tranquilo de experto es tan grave no
creo que la gente espere que esto suceda
en la universidad supuestamente con
mayor libertad de expresión ellos
intentaron convertirse en los primeros
en eliminar todas las historias todas
las partes de la historia dentro del
campus o pasajes face in side y gentes
la pieza fue erigida en 1997 el último
año de la ocupación británica de hong
kong durante años simbolizó una amplia
gama de libertades a diferencia de china
continental donde los eventos de
tienanmen se han borrado en gran medida
la universidad cito razones legales para
el desmantelamiento de la estatua
durante los últimos dos años beijing ha
tomado medidas enérgicas contra las
manifestaciones a favor de la democracia
en hong kong según la ley de seguridad
que otorga a china la capacidad de
intervenir y frenar las protestas y el
discurso varios líderes pro democracias
y organizadores de las conmemoraciones
de tiananmen han sido arrestados en el
pasado las vigilias atraían a decenas de
miles en hong kong
el parlamento libio ordenó la formación
de un comité para crear una hoja de ruta
para el período posterior al 24 de
diciembre fecha en las que estaban
previstas las elecciones presidenciales
y legislativas que fueron canceladas
luego de que el comité electoral
encargado asegurara que es imposible
realizarlas los comicios serán
considerados una oportunidad clave para
regresarle la estabilidad del país que
lleva una década a sumido en el caos
y rechazamos cualquier intento de pasar
por encima de la voluntad popular que ha
expresado su deseo de realizar
elecciones del 24 de diciembre sabemos
que ya el tiempo ha pasado para esa
fecha pero hacemos énfasis e insistimos
en que la sesión que se llevará a cabo
en el parlamento el 27 de diciembre debe
llamar a unas elecciones urgentes y la
dejaba casi llegamos al final de esta
informativo a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]